if you were stuck in a Time Loop and
forced to die again and again what would
you do you're stuck on this island and
you'll be forced to see all of your
friends get brutally murdered until you
stop these horrifying monsters I'm going
to break down the mistakes made what you
should do and how to beat the shadow
aliens in summertime rendering this kid
has no idea that he's about to die over
and over again shinpei here has come
back to this town for his old friend's
funeral and he suddenly wakes up on this
boat after a crazy Nightmare and bothers
this glasses girl and gets a firm slap
to the face just as this ship arrives on
his hometown Island but he doesn't
realize that he's just entered a
horrifying time Loop he gets greeted by
his dead friend's sister Mio as she
hurtles down the street on her bicycle
and falls clumsily into the sea the two
start heading to Mio's sister's funeral
that is just about to start and they see
Mio's sister in a coffin suddenly Sheen
paint notices a mysterious flash go off
near him just as he gets hugged by his
old friend redhead guy he tells him that
this dead girl ushio died trying to save
this little girl from drowning but later
shinpei gets a call from redhead guy who
tells him that his dad the town's
coroner discovered marks on ushio's neck
and that he suspects that ushio was in
fact strangled to death Sheen pay freaks
the hell out but redhead guy tells him
that since no one else was near the area
when she died the police have labeled it
an accident the next day shinpei is at
his part-time job when the town's
policeman comes in for a break the cop
mentions to them that the girl that
ushio died trying to save has suddenly
vanished from the island along with her
family meal freaks out at this news and
then tells shinpei the most insane thing
ever she mentions that a few days before
ushio died they both saw a blonde girl
at the beach who looked just like ushio
suddenly this old man on the street
interrupts them and says that what Mio
and ushio saw was a shadow he tells them
all about this horrifying disease and
says that if they're sick with the
shadow curse they should go to the
island Temple to get cured Sheen pay
thinks the old man is crazy but takes
Mio to the temple to make her feel
better there Mio suddenly sees something
watching them in the forest and they go
to check it out but all they see is this
injured glasses girl the same girl from
the boat earlier she tries to tell
shinpei something important just as she
gets shot dead shinpe freaks out right
as he turns around and sees the most
horrifying thing Mio and her Shadow and
it shoots Mio right in the head and then
it kills Shin Pei but suddenly he wakes
back up on the boat from day one earlier
sitting right in front of the same girl
who just died seconds earlier glasses
girl okay I would be like holy [ __ ]
because this reeks of the Edge of
Tomorrow type of bull crap and shinpei
here is now officially the new Japanese
Tom Cruise this means that he should be
concerned as hell now there is a
possibility that his dream just now was
nothing more than a hyper-vivid dream
that could be explained by normal
circumstances because usually dreams
that end up predicting real life events
are caused by outside factors like
having existing knowledge of something
from beforehand this can help influence
the dream into predicting likely
real-life future outcomes and our brains
are naturally wired to be a predictive
machine constantly nitpicking and
predicting the future like when we try
to catch a ball in the air we know that
if someone throws a ball forward unless
they really suck it's suddenly not going
to go backwards and this kind of thought
pattern is known as causual reasoning
which is the process of identifying
causality in other words we're very good
at understanding the relationship
between cause and effect and this
learned to logic of reasoning is
important as it enables us to explain
and predict future events up to a point
however what's scary as hell here is
that Shin pays dream just now had too
many unique details about this island
that he hasn't been back to in over two
years therefore him knowing certain
information like who still lives there
or what would likely happen like Mio
falling into the ocean for example all
of this was way too specific to be
random we could argue that shinpei just
had a major case of deja vu but experts
generally agree that this phenomena
likely relates to memory in some way
this means that there's a reason behind
his crazy drantha just happened out of
the blue and I would pay attention to
everything that's about to happen next
in order to survive because from the
looks of things the end of this dream
did not look Pleasant Sheen paint freaks
the hell out as he stares at this soon
to be dead girl he calms himself down
and he gets off of the boat in complete
shock and he Witnesses the day go by
exactly as it had before he died meal
falling off the bike ushio's funeral and
the same mysterious flash that goes off
near him shinpei starts to think that he
may just be repainting the past which
means means that it won't be long before
he gets brutally murdered again that
night after he eats dinner with Mio's
family he tries to piece together what
the hell is really going on and then he
steps outside to take a breather but
that's when his nightmare starts all
over again and he sees Meo suddenly
outside and she has a knife Sheen pastes
Frozen and Confused horror as this cop
guy shows up to check to see if
everything is all right with me he gets
close to meal and she stabs him
senseless until he dies and that's when
shinpei realizes that this girl is not
meal but her alien Shadow suddenly a
bright flash erupts around us and
another Shadow appears taking the form
of the dead cop the shadow then flashes
cop guy again and his corpse disappears
from the face of the Earth leaving only
a burnt mark on the ground Mio's Shadow
then tells this Shadow His name his age
and personal information it then says
that it plans to kill the real Mio soon
when no one is looking suddenly Sheen
pays phone rings and he tries to turn it
off but just then he feels his body go
lifeless as he realizes that he's been
stabbed his soul is then teleported
through this tunnel of light right as he
runs into ushio who then tells him to
protect meal and suddenly he wakes up
again but this time he's not on the boat
he's already on the island he then sees
Mio come rushing down on her bike but
this time stops her before she gets
thrown into the ocean again this kid
knows what he's been seeing is real and
this time we'll make sure that the
monsters don't kill him or the ones that
he loves later he makes a prank call to
cop guy telling him that there's a crime
on the other side of the island saving
him from eventually meeting miel's
Shadow and he gets ready to film those
Shadow monsters for video proof good
thinking shinpei hides his phone in the
bushes for the night and the next
morning captures Mio's Shadow Right In
the Flesh he then chose Mio the video
proof and she's shocked and they both
realize that these Shadows are real and
more than likely killed ushio too well
that's just great just great Mio
confirmed it the video confirmed it
we've confirmed it with our own eyes we
are now stuck in some kind of horrifying
time Loop which means we've now
officially joined the ranks of both
Groundhog Day and The Edge of Tomorrow
which is really bad because while
notable scientists like Kip Thorne and
Stephen Hawking have declared that this
is technically impossible for the most
part there is still a way that we
somehow could have ended up in one the
general concept of time is that light
can bend gravity and the space-time
fabric which can be thought of as a
fabric blanket upon which all the
planets and the universe sit on when the
space-time fabric bends two points at
the ends chosen start to come closer to
each other there's one thing in the
universe strong enough to do this and
that's a black hole and these things are
totally insane I mean haven't you guys
seen the movie Interstellar I mean come
on a black hole can't form without a ton
of energy going around it faster than
the speed of light and is impossible
with our current technology however just
like the previously mentioned movie
Interstellar it's possible that shinpei
here got transported into a Time Loop
through a black hole created from the
future because usually these time Loops
are created from something with an end
goal in mind if we can find the cause of
this time Loop or reach our end goal
whatever that may be then this could in
theory bring us out of this horrifying
time Loop because there is one thing
that shinpei hasn't noticed that makes
all of this even more terrifying the
fact is that each time he comes back to
life he's restarted his day closer and
closer to the time of his death in the
time Loop have you guys noticed it I
should this means that he can't keep
dying again and again without
consequences because eventually one of
those deaths will be his final one so I
would maybe dial it back a bit and not
be as Reckless and be super cautious as
possible and throw as many people under
the bus as I need to in order to stay
alive long enough in order to get to the
bottom of this that's what I would do
shinpe then investigates The
Disappearance of the little girl's
family and he pays a visit to their
empty house inside he sees the same
horrifying black figure marks on the
floor the same ones that he saw in the
other time Loop this is the work of
those horror flying Shadows he walks
upstairs into this dark hallway and is
about to turn on the light when suddenly
he sees another bright flash turning
around he sees the little girl's Shadow
it states that its name is shiori and It
prepares to take his soul and kill him
right now but all of a sudden the
neighbor who let him in walks up to
check on him causing the terrifying
Shadows to vanish horrified this kid
decides to waste no time and asks around
the town if anybody has seen the one
person from his time Loop that doesn't
make sense the woman from the boat
glasses girl but while asking around he
runs into cop guy again who gives
shinpei a mysterious phone belonging to
ushi he mentions that she wanted him to
have it in case anything happened to her
they then meet up with redhead guy and
these two finally decide to let him in
on what's really going on they fill him
in on ushio's murder and the horrifying
Shadow aliens but redhead guy can't
believe what he's hearing and they
discuss if there's any way to tell these
Shadows apart from real human being okay
good these people have finally started
to strain up and are beginning to sort
some [ __ ] out took them long enough
despite the Shadows being able to take
on human form expanding our team is the
best move that we can do since we're up
against an unknown threat if anything I
would work on letting as many people in
on this as I can but without video proof
it's unlikely that they'll believe us
which is why from here on out I would
work on investing in as much recording
equipment as we can such as GoPros trail
cameras security cameras whatever we can
get our hands on and with this stuff
we'll be able to document everything
that we see from here on out now while
the Shadows may look like humans there
is one method that we could use to
figure out who's a shadow and who is a
normal human if we remember when shinpei
witnessed cop guy getting killed Mio's
Shadow clearly and verbally told him his
identity and age and this means that
despite being an exact copy these
Shadows have limited information about
who they're imitating and we can use
this to our Advan we could begin having
conversations with people with the goal
of being able to catch them out with
what they say if someone was a shadow
based on what we saw with cop guy they
wouldn't be able to know all the
intimate details about the person
They're copying and knowing this will be
able to better tell who's a shadow and
who is not while this doesn't solve our
shadow alien problem this definitely
will allow us to expand our team and
lessen the risk of a shadow infiltrating
our team and while these Shadows may be
Celestial the fact that we have video
proof of these things means that they're
definitely not any type of apparition or
ookie spooky ghost which means we have a
better shot of defeating them however
small it may be xingpade tells the gang
that there's no way to tell a shadow
apart from a human Mio then asks if they
should go to the shrine to try to figure
out how to stop the Shadows at least
according to the myth but shinpei says
that they should wait until tomorrow and
do it during the popular Summer Festival
where it'll be more crowded and safer
and so the gang prepares for what's to
come but they have no idea that they
will be all dead before tomorrow night
the next day they suit up kimono style
and head to the festival but shinpei
here suddenly sees ushio in the distance
alive confused as hell shinpei
desperately chases after her to the
beach after talking with her he realizes
that this ushio is a shadow she then
simps out a little bit and tells shinpei
that she loves him and this kid gets
even more confused he grabs her and
decides to hide her before any one of
his friends see her they talk it out for
a hot SEC and then ushio tells shinpei
that she has all of ushio's memories
showing that she's the perfect copy of
ushio herself but she's not evil now
getting even more confused shinpei tells
her to stay here for a bit while he
heads to the shrine to meet the gang but
he doesn't know that his life is about
to get a whole lot worse on the way to
the shrine he runs into none other than
Mio's Shadow horrifying him the shadow
then asks how he knew to record her the
other day and it readies its knife then
suddenly Shin pays Shadow pops up
copying his memories with this Flash and
it finds out his and Mio's plan Mio's
Shadow prepares to kill shinpei but is
stopped by shinpei's Shadow as it knows
about his time traveling Powers if he
doesn't die then he can't start over Mio
Shadow then breaks his arm and shinpei
shadow goes to meet the gang but
suddenly one of them is shot dead by
none other than glasses girl who tells
this kid that she's been here to save
him she then fills him in on everything
that she knows about the Shadows how
they feed on human data and that these
creatures have shadows themselves that
forbid anyone or anything from stepping
on them when they're undercover and this
is the way to tell them apart suddenly
they see a bright flash at the top of
the hill and they know that means
trouble they rush to go to look for
shinpei's friends when they come across
the most horrifying thing the Shadows
have killed everyone at the festival
Gathering and have made a mountain of
corpses this OG Shadow declares that the
hour of nine approaches as he stands in
front of them triumphant and this
monster is more powerful than anything
they've ever seen shinpei freezes up
just as he sees his best buddy redhead
guy get fudged up in the face with an ax
gross suddenly glasses grow Spidey
senses start to tingle and she barely
avoids her death this OG Shadow then
grabs Shin paper notices that one of
shimpei's eyes belongs to their Shadow
mother the God of this island and ruler
of the Shadows this monster cannot
believe it telling shinpei that the eye
can control the flow of time allowing
the user to restart the day from a saved
point and this creature is about to
gouge out chimpei's eye in order to
reawaken their mother okay this is
really bad because just like how I
mentioned earlier about us needing to
find out our true objective on why we're
stuck here in this time Loop uh I think
I found it this is as good an
explanation as any and this means that
we are now at the very least not in the
dark about what's really going on
however shinpei acted carelessly and
didn't stop to think that he himself
self was the most valuable person here
at least up until now even if ushio's
Shadow here proved herself to be a
valuable Ally disappearing off by
himself to go track her down led him to
nearly getting captured by Mio Shadow
and this type of carelessness could have
been avoided if he just chose to not act
like an idiot I could have told you even
before OG's Shadow revealed to us about
shinpei's eye which by the way is
stunning I mean have you looked at that
eyeball that is one blue eyeball I could
have told you that shinpei was the most
important person here since he was
clearly the only one who had this time
traveling ability and again even once
coming across OG's Shadow while this kid
did stick around long enough to find out
this Vital Information which was good he
should have been prepared to have some
sort of Exit Plan since he already knew
that [ __ ] could have gone South at any
minute and in reality shipei should have
been carrying a gray matter Blaster of
his own I mean he's clearly old enough
to be able to manage his own power once
he found out the Shadow's true plan
instead of just standing there like a
deer in the headlights he should have
spent less time yapping more time
focusing on himself if you know what I
mean this at the very least would have
allowed shinpei to better control his
fate and could have prevented him from
inevitably being at the mercy of OG's
Shadow since it was clear from the
get-go that this dude was truly the
original Shadow gangster OG Shadow drops
shinpei as he and his minions swallow up
ushio and Mio right in front of him
preparing a human Feast OG's Shadow
offers up this meal along with the rest
of the people on the island to the
shadow God everyone around shimpei dies
which means he needs to reset the time
Loop he desperately yells out for
glasses girl to reset his time Loop she
aims the gun at his face and tells him
to come find her when he wakes up she
blows his head off and shinpei resets
the entire day waking up already on the
island and with Mio this time he begins
to realize that each time Loop resets
him minutes closer to his actual death
so he starts to prepare to stop the
alien Shadows before they kill everyone
at the Summer Festival in three days
time elsewhere glasses girl realizes
that more people at this funeral have
been turned into shadows and that their
army is growing she meets up with old
man and hands him her second phone
telling him to call her if it rings
arriving at the funeral shinpei gets to
work and tries to find out more
information about the shadows and the
Shadow's sickness he also asks around
about glasses girl and this guy ends up
giving him her phone number desperate to
contact her he calls the number and an
unfamiliar voice picks up it's old man
and he cautiously tells shinpei to meet
him in the jungle immediately she
arrives with a ton of questions and here
he finally meets glasses girl he tells
the stranger her full name and glasses
girl realizes that shinpei here is a
time traveler she tells him that her
family was murdered by Shadows years ago
but doesn't mention why she came back or
why she's trying to save shinpei at all
just that Shadows Target families on
this island which is why Mio and shimpei
aren't safe old man also reveals that
when a person's Shadow is destroyed they
gain immunity for life making it
impossible for another shadow of their
to be created the three then devise a
plan to stop the shadows and shinpei
says that they have three days before
the Shadows kill everyone at the Summer
Festival knowing what Horrors await
shinpei says that they must stop
chiore's powerful Shadow first and so
the group heads over to shiori's house
to carry out their Shadow killing plan
but at the house glasses girl decides to
go in and do the killing herself and
shinpeihir also discovers that she has
two personalities her dead brother's
personality takes over her body Whenever
there is conflict tying up her hair
whenever his personality shows up and so
glasses girl personality switches over
to her dead Brothers glasses guy and
they head into the house to take out the
shadows and this crazy chick Hammer
Slinger swings and stings shiori's
entire Shadow family it was beautiful
killing all of them but shiori glasses
girl then realizes that shiroi's shadow
is more powerful than the rest and she
calls old man and shinpei to switch to
plan B chasing the Shadow outside of the
house until they capture her thanks to
the dart gun they figured out a new way
to capture Shadows but shiori's Shadow
then reveals that she was the one who
killed she impaced ushio enraging him
right until glasses guy kills shiori's
Shadow glasses guy tells shinpei that a
lethal blow to the Shadow's platform on
the ground is the only way to kill it
and the Gang then prepares for their
next Target to kill Mio's shadow that
according to shinpei will show up at
Mio's house tonight just like it did in
the first time Loop okay this is insane
and glasses girl's multiple personality
disorder is starting to make me think
that all crazies this bad deserve to be
wifed up I mean I'm sure they're really
cool but all this Hammer swinging and
stinging makes me think that shinpei
here forgot to stop and think about how
his actions here could have impacted the
future it's noted that shinpei is
currently stuck in a Time Loop but is
trying to get to the bottom of this
Shadow's mystery he should have gone
into the spirit of all of this time
traveler-ness by at the very least
acknowledging the underlying principle
of a mathematical term known as Chaos
Theory which is the study of apparent
random or unpredictable behavior and
systems governed by deterministic laws
or in other words the butterfly effect
which is considered an underlying
principle of Chaos Theory which
describes how a small change in one
state of a fixed reality can result in
large differences at a later point
shimpei is assuming that his
ever-changing actions would result in
all future events still showing up the
way he remembered it that's not how it
works whether that was with Mio's
Shadows showing up at the real meals
house to kill her at the exact same time
and place no matter what or that each of
the Shadows he encountered were going to
show up in the same place and time as
they did in all the other past time
Loops chimpei should have thought at the
very least to kind of think like Doctor
Who for a minute and assume that in
going after shuri's family in this time
Loop this act and all his other acts
could have potentially affected all
future events changing them and altering
them to something different than what
chimpei knows it's like as if you saw
your friend get into a car crash and
then got the chance to go back in time
to try and stop it by you simply going
back in time and trying to stop your
friend friends car crash this action
would likely alter that reality and
result in a different outcome for your
friend than what you saw in the present
if we use classic time traveler logic
then it stands to reason that shinpei
going after shori's family in this time
Loop means that he'll likely alter some
future event which means that going
forward shinpei will need to pay super
close attention even more and not assume
that the future will play out exactly as
it did in this last time Loop later at
Mio's house shinpeo waits for her
murderous Shadow to show up just as he
is surprised by ushio's Shadow shinpei
freaks out and hides her before anyone
sees her leading her into this room and
he stares at her and wonders if she is
an evil Shadow or not but she tells him
that she followed him from his last time
Loop and that she wants to help him stop
the Shadows from taking over suddenly
someone knocks at their door Lucio
Shadow hides as Mio comes in to take the
dishes shinpei then tells uzio's Shadow
what's going on and that Mio Shadow will
try to kill her tonight and the two sit
tight and prepare for what's to come but
that was their biggest take suddenly
another knock is heard at the door
shinpei opens it and sees Mio again but
something is not right and he sees her
take on a knife and try to stab him
ushio jumps out to try to protect him
getting stabbed in the process and they
realize that this is Mio's Shadow this
monster tries to kill shinpei but gets
protected by ushio Shadow and she gets
fatally wounded in the process confused
Mio's Shadow asks her why it wants to
protect shimpei when it's just a monster
like her and ushio's Shadow says that
she'll do anything to protect him
because they're family just then Mio
shadow gets a head blown off by old man
sniper and glasses guy busts in and
prepares to kill usio's Shadow but
suddenly he recognizes her voice and
glasses guy realizes that ushio shadow
was the one who told glasses girl to
come to the island in the first place
later the group gathers and glasses girl
now switched back to her old self shows
ushio the voice note that she left her
warning glasses girl about the island
getting taken over by shadows and how
shinpei was the only one who could stop
that but ushio has no memory of ever
sending the voice note there's something
more horrifying going on because in all
the other time Loops Mio Shadow never
went inside meo's house to kill her
which means shinpei's actions in this
time Loop have caused the future to
change basically making shinpei useless
not really and they realized that the
Shadows must be communicating with each
other since no other Shadow was around
when shiori's Shadow was killed this
makes glasses girl realize that they
can't trust any Shadow and decides to
split from shimpei and ushio shinpei
then tells her of her impending death in
the forest like in his first time Loop
before they part ways the next day on
July 23rd shinpei and ushio decide to
finally unveil what's going on to
redhead guy and he joins their Shadow
fighting team once again okay I'm
starting to get stressed out now this is
getting bad [ __ ] crazy and hard to keep
track of because Mio Shadow changing her
actions just now and going inside the
house proves that the butterfly effect
here is a real deal kind of thing which
means that as I mentioned earlier the
more time shinpei resets the day the
more that he's going to have to be aware
of since his actions in order to save
this Village and all of his friends will
mean that he needs to meddle in the past
more and more in order to pull this all
off there are two things here that make
shinpei's situation even more terrifying
each time shinpei resets his time Loop
he resets closer to the time of his
death at the Summer Festival which means
the consequences of some of his actions
in his previous time Loop will
eventually carry over to each new time
Loop remember when his new reset point
was after when he decided to save Mio
from falling into the ocean this means
that each time shinpei resets his time
Loop his new reality will become
progressively more permanent since his
actions in each time Loop along with him
resetting at a later Point means that
certain outcomes will inevitably happen
in ways that shinpei will not be able to
reset like when shinpei killed shiori
and her family for example there were no
other shadows in the area which means
there was no reason for them to switch
their tactics in the first place in
order to try and throw shimpei off the
scent like with Mio's Shadow entering
Mayo's house in this time Loop for
example this likely proves my theory
that by simply interacting with the
shadows and killing them one by one
shinpei has already altered the past in
this time Loop and has made the future
outcome of all of this different from
what he remembers and that means that
shimpei needs to be super careful and
consider how even if he kills these
shadows in secret killing them
regardless could change everything for
the worse that's a lot of pressure the
gang then decides to look through
ushio's phone that was given to shinpei
earlier after ushio's Shadow unlocks it
they see a video message showing ushio
from the past along with her Shadow and
in the message the real ushio says that
her Shadow is their Ally and she
explains the events that led to her
death the ushio in the video Then goes
on to say that a few days before her
death shuri came to the real ushio or
scared and mentioned that she saw a copy
of herself then later ushio also saw a
copy of herself on the beach and that's
when she decided to help shiori
investigate these strange events but
later she discovered her own shadow
however ushio's Shadow couldn't remember
why it was there in the first place and
because of all of this strangeness the
two girls then decide to team up to get
to the bottom of the mystery later they
discovered an old clinic in the
mountains thanks to Shadow ushio's vague
memory of it being there before but it
is here when ushio Shadow realized its
powers due to them being forced to fight
this evil Shadow the real usual then
mentions in the video that once the
original person dies the shadow copy of
that person basically becomes the real
version even though it's a shadow
suddenly ushio Shadow then regains all
of her memories and Powers it is here
that shadow usho then decides to show
these two guys her memories of the real
ushio's death she takes them back to the
day that ushio died and they see the two
ushios planning to protect shiori oh how
nice just as shadow ushio goes
undercover and turns into a necklace for
the real ushio to wear just then surely
disappeared which forced both of the two
girls to try and save her life however
the evil Shadow that took the real
shiori was too strong and it eventually
killed the real usio and wounded ushio
Shadow erasing her memories in the
process this is how the real ushio died
and the Gang then vows to stop all of
the Shadows before the Summer Festival
suddenly shiori's Shadow appears out of
nowhere transforming into the same
island God that shinpei saw at the
festival she grabs his arm and marks him
before ushio Shadow Returns the gang out
from her memory with less than 24 hours
to go until the summer Festival begins
they waste no time and head to the old
clinic in the mountains that ushio
shadow showed them in the video later
they reached the clinic and see an old
statue of the god of the island redhead
guy then says that he's been here before
as a kid and this used to be run by his
dad's grandfather and his grandfather
before him but has since closed down
Shadow usho then finds a secret door
hiding behind one of the walls and uses
her powers to find the door key hiding
inside the Statue she then copies the
key but all of a sudden her stomach
growls not realizing that this is a
terrifying sign for things to come
shinpei then feeds Shadow ushio a rice
ball and the three then entered the
Secret Door leading deep into the sewers
however here they discover a horrifying
Baby Shadow Monster with no head they
think it can't see them so they try to
get closer to kill it but that was their
biggest mistake suddenly they realized
it can smell them and it brutally
attacks redhead guy nearly killing
everyone okay these baby Shadows are the
exact reason why kids are the most
horrifying thing in this world but
seeing these little Shadows slightly
deformed makes me think that they
haven't reached their full maturity or
at the very least were taken out of the
oven too soon looks like they've been
deprived from human meat or at least
something for a while but regardless
shimpei should have been a little more
careful and should not have assumed that
they were as doll silent harmless as
normal human babies because they're not
human babies also while these Shadows
Didn't Have Eyes it stands to reason
that shinpei and crew could have still
assumed that they would have had
external senses that could have enabled
these shadow babies to bypass the fact
that they couldn't see and were still
able to see shinpei another way
regardless I mean the god noses on these
things this means that eyes are not
Champa should have proceeded way more
cautiously and should not have acted
like a complete and total schmuck the
gang fights back against this Shadow and
finally managed to defeat it but Shadow
ushio detects more Shadows nearby and
suddenly realizes that her arm from when
she fought Mio Shadow earlier still
hasn't healed and the pain is starting
to get worse knowing that their time is
running out she ignores the pain and
continues on later they reach this
underground Cavern when all of a sudden
Shadow ushio realizes that they're
surrounded by hundreds of baby shadows
and these monsters get ready to kill
them meanwhile near the surface glasses
girl and old man decide to check out the
sewers thanks to glasses girl's
premonition Powers inside she switches
to her second male personality and
transforms once again into glasses guy
down there they run into Mio and cop guy
who both thought they saw shiori go down
into the sewers however glasses guy
knows something is not right and these
two decide to go into the sewers more
slowly but they have no idea what
horrifying things are about to happen
meanwhile back at shinpei's group the
gang fights hard to stop these shadow
monsters from consuming their souls but
then they realize that shadow ushio's
arm injury is still a major problem in
order to minimize the paint Shadow ushio
erases her arm just as they discover
something horrifying its redhead guy's
sister redhead girl and she shows up
with two huge Shadow bodyguards and
declares that she's come to take Shadow
ushio from them she then reveals a
terrifying secret she is human and their
father the town's corner and their
entire family has been working with the
shadows for years feeding them and
keeping them a secret from the rest of
the island including redhead guy since
they thought he didn't have what it
takes to be a part of the family
business redhead guy is totally shell
shocked and shinpei decides to follow
redhead girl to discover what's really
going on before he time Loops back they
reach this cave entrance and then they
discover the Island God that shinpei saw
at the Summer Festival and it changes
its appearance from shiori to this
white-haired little girl redhead girl
introduces the island God as high and
reveals that this is the first person to
be copied by this Shadow God Sheen pay
is horrified to see the one person who
killed his entire family Hein reveals
that she's been weak this whole time and
needs to be fed soon and it is at this
moment that shinpei realizes that it is
this God that will swallow up the entire
Island in less than 24 hours two coffins
then enter the cave being led by a nurse
that works for Redhead guy's dad they
then find out that redhead guy's family
has been feeding this island God for
years in exchange for the Shadows to
keep redhead guy's mother alive as a
shadow but they don't have time to react
as they see something even worse and see
the real ushio's corpse inside this
coffin finding out that the Shadows
stole the real ushio's corpse the day
before her funeral horrified shinpei
tries to think fast and slowly takes out
a strand of ushio's hair knowing that
the only way Shadow ushio can heal
herself is to absorb the real ushio's
corpse before Hein does he calls out for
shadow ushio as she suddenly uses her
Shadow powers to turn her strand of hair
into a nail gun shinpei then Fires at
the shadow giving ushio enough time to
escape and steal the real ushio's corpse
Hein gets angry and turns this nurse who
we find out is a shadow into a
horrifying Beast it charges at shinpei
as ushio distracts it shinpei then uses
this time to try and kill Hein but
suddenly has his fingers brutally cut
off by OG's Shadow shinpei crumples down
in pain as OG's Shadow reveals that it's
caught Mio and is using her as his
hostage however redhead girl is
horrified as hell and tells OG's shadow
that using Mio was never part of the
plan but it then reveals that they're
just using redhead girl in her family
and it tries to kill her but her brother
jumps in the way and takes the bullet
instead and he dies right in front of
her and OG Shadow says to her that her
father already knows the real plan
terrified OG Shadow then puts a big
fatty right through her gray matter and
attempts to reprogram ushio's Shadow
okay we finally have a face to put
towards who's running this show and it
ain't OG Shadow this poor girl's body
was the first sucker to get taken over
by this island God and this explains why
shori's Shadow up until now was so
strong as even glasses girl commented on
this when she fought it earlier but the
fact is that we can't kill her without a
pause realistically speaking and chimpei
here looks like he could use a hand or
at least a finger because at this point
there is literally nothing else that we
can do but extinguish ourselves and
start over if you know what I mean which
will then allow him to reset to go back
in time and start this whole thing over
again hopefully this time with better
results elsewhere glasses guy and old
man continue down the tunnel when they
discover a copy of the island God on
patrol in Disguise as shiori's Shadow
shuri then warns OG's Shadow about this
glasses guy's powers to sense danger
before it happens and then uses this
information to kill old man and mortally
wound glasses guy as he desperately
tries to run away about to die glasses
guy swaps back to his other personality
and lets down her hair turning back into
glass's girl suddenly cop guy runs into
her and mentions that some monster came
and took a meal earlier Bleeding Out
glasses girl tells cop guy to bring her
to shimpei so she can reset the time
Loop before they lose everything else
where shinpei now injured begs Hind to
spare ushio's Shadow but Hein ignores
him and brutally rips out his eyeball
which she says grants him the ability to
time Jump but then shimpei's eye then
disappears from her hand and appears
back inside of shimpei shinpei has one
more trick up his sleeve and quickly
tries to take out something from his
pocket but he is suddenly grabbed by
OG's Shadow as hind realizes that this
kid is becoming more powerful and that
it won't be too long until shinpei can
control his powers but OG's Shadow
thinks shinpei is still too weak and
can't do [ __ ] so he brutally crushes
meal's face like a Japanese egg and he
laughs in shimpei's horrified face he
tells Shin pit that he will stay on live
until the summer Festival tomorrow night
where he will be forced to watch as
everyone he loves dies for the final
time suddenly OG's shadow gets shot by
glasses girl and cop guy as she helps
break ushio free just then she gets shot
right through her meaty eyeball turning
glasses girl into glasses Cyclops and
then she and cop guy then collapse to
the floor and die shimpei looks in
horror as OG Shadow says that this is
the end for Humanity but shinpei finally
manages to take out the one thing from
the pocket that will change everything
and OG shadow sees shinpei drops
something that turns his smile upside
down but what did you guys think about
it let us know what you like about the
video and what you didn't like about the
video don't forget to like subscribe and
as always don't forget to check out our
social media and a very Happy
Thanksgiving to everyone